number one joe biden um continued
signing executive orders yesterday he
signed i think what is it i think he's
up to 5 000 executive orders so far
just he wakes up in the morning and
whatever thought he happens to think
that day he'll convert it into a
executive order i think he'll be signing
an executive order today to declare that
chipmunks are the cutest forest animals
anything at all any thought he happens
to think
let's make it into an executive order
but remember of course
trump was the the dictator and the
fascist
um biden will beat
trump's executive order total in like a
few months
that's that's that's the rate he's on
now um and so
on that end yesterday he signed he
signed a
racial equity executive order and of
course he tied it to
george floyd here he is explaining why
he's signing the order
but what many americans didn't see her
had simply refused to see
couldn't be ignored any longer those
uh eight minutes and 46 seconds that
took
george floyd's life opened the eyes of
millions of americans and millions of
people around all over the world
it was the knee on the neck of justice
and it wouldn't be forgotten it stirred
the conscious
and of tens of millions of americans and
in my view it marked a turning point
in this country's attitude toward racial
justice
yeah eye-opening moment you know i
thought it was pretty eye-opening
when we got the toxicology report back
and uh
we were told that he had lethal levels
of fentanyl in a system
i thought that was pretty eye opening
too um that that that to me was pretty
enlightening as well
now joe biden also uh we we talked last
week about the 1776 commission
that president trump formed and they
released their report which we we went
through a little bit of it
uh worth reading except that you can't
read it because one of the first things
that
biden did when he took office he deleted
it he took it down
and now he announced part of this part
of this racial equity plan
is to do away with the 1776 commission
he is explaining that
look in the weeks ahead i'll be uh
reaffirming the federal government's
commitment to diversity equity and
inclusion
and accessibility building on the work
we started
in the obama biden administration that's
why
i'm rescinded the previous
administration's harmful ban on
diversity and sensitivity training
and abolish the offensive counter
factual 1776 commission
unity and healing must begin with
understanding and truth not ignorance
and lies
today i'm also issuing an executive
order
and that will ultimately end the justice
department's use of private prisons
private prisons an industry that houses
pre-child attainees and detainees and
federal prisoners
the executive order directs the attorney
general to decline to renew contracts
with privately operated criminal
facilities
a step we started to take at the end of
the obama administration
and was reversed under the previous
administration
yeah so he talks about there abolishing
the uh the 1776 commission
you know and he he also says he also
says it's it's count counterfactual
is the 17th what part of it is
counterfactual
the the the report lays out
basic facts of american history and as
soon as it was released we were told by
the media and the left that oh it's
it's an assault on truth and on this is
not history at all
what part of it isn't history
you know they they never explained that
did they
they never told us exactly what part of
it is false
of course the the only part they really
the the primary part they disagree with
is just the point that the 1776
commission made
which is that slavery an awful evil
thing
nobody didn't literally nobody at least
nobody in the west denies it
um some parts of the world where they
still have slavery maybe they do deny it
but certainly in the west nobody denies
that
but it's also not a crime or a sin
unique to western society the white man
didn't invent slavery
that does matter you know that matters
because when we're going back and we're
looking at our um the heroes of our
history
we have to understand them within
context
and if there's a certain evil thing that
someone in history
uh took part in or
at least did not object to and then you
and then you and then you take and then
you take a step back and you
take a wider view of it and you see that
pretty much everyone
in history up until that point also was
not objecting to it
then yeah that that matters not i don't
know how many times i have to explain
this that matters
not in judging the objective um morality
of the act itself now we know that
slavery
is a horrible evil always has been
always will be
and you can make statements like that
when you believe in objective morality
the the irony here is at the left
they're moral relativists
so they have even less standing to judge
anyone 200 years ago
who practiced slavery or believed in it
because according to them
morality is relative and 200 years ago
250 years ago 300 years ago all
throughout history
the the relative morality of that time
was that slavery was okay
if you're a more relativist you have no
basis upon which to criticize that
now if you believe in objective morality
as i do then i can say
250 years ago if you practice slavery or
or
or even fail to protest against it
then that is an evil act
but when judging the moral culpability
of any individual who engaged in it
that's when you have to take into
account
context the context of the time
um and that's the difference
but again as a moral relativist that is
just the
the incredible irony here it's the moral
relativists
who are the ones going back through
history
and holding you know our historical
figures to the standards of today
i think that's stupid to do on any
philosophical grounds
you especially can't do it as a
relativist makes no sense
all right one other clip i wanted to
play because because uh biden has one
other thing to say here that i thought
was
was was interesting but not for the
reason he intended let's take a listen
we've never fully lived up to the
founding principles of this nation
state the obvious that all people are
created equal and have a right to be
treated equally throughout their lives
and it's time to act now not only
because it's the right thing to do
but because if we do we'll all be better
off for it
for too long we've allowed a narrow
cramped view
of the promise of this nation to fester
you know we've uh we've bought the view
that america is a zero-sum game in many
cases
if you succeed i fail if you get ahead i
fall behind
if you get the job i lose mine maybe
worst of all
if i hold you down i lift myself up
yeah i actually agree with him there i
agree with what he just said
um but i don't think he understands
what he's saying and i think that's a
problem that's still going to get worse
as time goes on
but he's saying we've bought this
incorrect view that america is a is a
zero-sum game and you know if i succeed
it means you fail
you're right that is that is an
incorrect view
it is a view that a lot of people have
bought into it is wrong
we do need to push back against it but
that's the view that is being propagated
by your side
dude that's that's you that's you and
your side that's what you're saying
we here over here as conservatives we've
been we have been the ones saying what
you just said
that's not the way it works that's why
you don't have to look with resentment
on someone who's wealthy and successful
just because someone's wealthy
successful it doesn't mean they're
taking something away from you
you don't have to take from from someone
in order for other people to be
successful if you want to help the less
successful be more successful doesn't
mean you have to take away
from the ones who are successful because
because it's not a zero-sum game
that is an incorrect view but again
biden
it's your view not ours
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content